how's it going everybody it's warren and
wanda vision episode 7
finally gave us some answers and if you
haven't seen it yet and are trying to
avoid spoilers here is your official
warning because we're going to dive
right into everything that happened as
we've been saying
it was agatha harkness the whole entire
time
wanda was not the one responsible for
everything that was happening
secretly behind the scenes it was agatha
harkness the nosy neighbor
agnes and kudos to marvel studios for
making
us kind of doubt that agnes was actually
agatha hartness
but now all has been revealed or at
least we're made to believe
that everything has been revealed but i
think there's still more to this that we
have not seen yet
so for this breakdown i'm going to start
off by talking about agatha harkness
the villain of one division what role
the fox version of quicksilver is
actually playing here
what happened to the twins talk about
that mystical book inside of agatha's
lair
and what i think is going to happen in
one division and the future of the mcu
and then we'll get into the easter eggs
of this episode
and as always if you love marvel content
be sure to subscribe hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
so we were right the entire time the ag
in agnes was part of agatha and the ness
in agnes was of course
harkness now agatha harkness is a very
very ancient witch in the comics she was
old enough to remember
500 years before atlantis sank to the
bottom of the sea
so she's thousands of years old which
means she is very
experienced in witchcraft in fact she
was involved in the salem witch trials
which took place in
new jersey which they currently are at
and it looks like she's been there for a
while since she has a massive layer
underneath her basement
now of course now the big question is
what exactly is agatha's plan
with wanda and what did she do to the
twins
well it's very clear that agatha wanted
the twins from the beginning
since the very first episode wanda was
made to think about children then of
course she was magically pregnant and
had the twin boys
and agatha was very involved in the
whole entire process
and agatha was controlling every other
person that was talking to her
about kids as well and why did agatha
finally reveal herself
to wanda because she finally got the
twin boys when wanda goes into agatha's
house and agatha says she'll make her
some tea
wanda looks around and notices that the
twins aren't there they were there she
can see the eaton sandwiches that they
once were eating but they're not
anywhere to be seen
want to ask where they are and agatha
very intentionally
tells her they're probably playing in
the basement this is because
agatha wants wanda to go into the
basement and see
who she really is she wants to reveal
everything to her
furthering the point that this was all
about the two kids the entire time
and her plan is complete or mostly
complete now that she has the kids
so what does she want with the kids the
nexus commercial that we got in this
episode
is very revealing as far as what
agatha's actual plans are and what
wanda's role is
in these plans now the nexus commercial
is clearly about wanda
it talks about if you are depressed
which we know wanda was you can take
this nexus pill that will anchor you
back to your reality
or the reality of your choice but the
commercial hints to what is about to
happen
the commercial says that the side
effects include feeling your feelings
confronting
your truth seizing your destiny and
possibly
more depression now this is what wanda
is about to do
the whole entire episode wanda has kind
of been depressed she's kind of stopped
caring she tells her kids that she
doesn't really have any of the answers
she says i'd get up but i don't want to
but then she confronts the truth the
truth that
agatha is actually the one in control of
everything but agatha has a destiny
planned out for wanda a purpose for
wanda that wanda is about to confront
and that involves taking away her kids
which is why she is going to be
depressed again
now the commercial is for nexus and a
nexus is a connection or a
link to something which is what agatha
truly needs and what she's getting from
the twins
agatha is not working alone she is
trying to bring somebody into our
dimension
or our reality and she needs a nexus a
connection or a link
to do so and that link is wanda and her
boys because this goes back to what
we've been saying
for a very long time since before one
division even premiered
and that is the villain is mephisto or
some amalgamation
and combining of him and nightmare
because as we know the twins aren't
visions kids wanda is magically pregnant
she doesn't get impregnated by vision
that's impossible
he's a synthezoid he's not human so
wanda was impregnated by magic
just like she was in the comics and what
really happened was was the twins were
shards of mephisto
soul and it seems like that kind of
remains true for wanda vision
mephisto or nightmare perhaps
combination of the both of them
is stuck in a realm and can't get to
this earth realm
and the only way that they can get to
the earth realm is if some part of them
ends up in there once a part of them is
in the earth realm agatha can use her
witchcraft to bring them completely
into the earth realm so the villain
impregnated wanda to get a part of him
inside of this earth realm making it
possible for agatha to bring him
completely into the realm and now
agatha has taken the twin boys and this
is why so she can bring the villain
into the realm now side note the villain
could also be her son
nicholas scratch this is kind of hinted
to at agatha harkness's bunny
senior scratchy now it could just be a
little node to her son nicola scratch or
it could actually be him
and he's the one that she's trying to
bring into this realm now this did
actually happen in the comics and the
nexus that was used was actually the
bodies of the fantastic
four members and more on them in the
breakdown because we didn't find out who
the engineer was
in this episode so a similar story could
be happening here
nicholas scratch agatha harkness's son
is in a different realm and she needs
to bring him into this realm so it could
be nightmare and or
mephisto that agatha is trying to
essentially summon
into their realm now how exactly will
agatha summon
this villain into their realm well she's
going to use that mystical
book that was shown in her lair that
book was the dark hold
also known as the book of sins or the
book of spells and it's an ancient book
of spells
and unspeakable power now this was
created
billions of years ago by the evil elder
god chathan
before he ended up being forced to earth
he wrote all of his evil works and
spells into an indestructible parchment
of flesh
and he created this at vundigor mountain
now vundegore mountain actually has a
connection to the scarlet witch this is
where the high evolutionary enhanced
wanda making her a conduit of chaos
magic
but if you are trying to summon somebody
truly evil such as nightmare or mephisto
or perhaps your son bringing them in
from a different dimension the dark
hold is definitely how you're going to
do it and that's why they put so much
emphasis on showing this for a few
seconds in agatha's lair
and that's what i believe is going to be
in store for wanda in the upcoming
episodes
now it was revealed that agatha was
actually the one controlling pietro the
whole entire time and let's talk about
that post
credit scene of course agatha took wanda
into her house
monica followed behind and is snooping
around trying to look inside to see
what's going on
and in the post-credit scene as she's
looking around she opens up a door to
agatha's lair and then quicksilver comes
up to her and says
snoopers gonna snoop now they made it
very clear in this episode that agnes
was indeed
controlling or maybe she even created
quicksilver but what i'm guessing is
since
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is supposed to be about the
multiverse in
madness is that agatha truly did pluck
fox's quicksilver from that fox universe
and bring him
into the mcu then she took control over
him just like she took control over
every single person in the town
so in this post credit scene when he
goes up to monica i do believe he is
still
under the control of agatha and he's
most likely going to take her
into that basement and show her to
agatha but she has officially become
photon she has her powers now and monica
combined with wanda and then vision when
he eventually shows up
might be strong enough to break free
from agatha and that's something that i
think we're going to see in the next
episode of one division episode 8.
so now that i've explained agatha
harkness and the post-credits scene
let's dive into
a shot for shot breakdown talk about the
easter eggs and all of the references
this episode starts off with a scene
that marvel studios actually released
on good morning america and then they
posted to their youtube page
yesterday she talks to the camera just
like the characters in modern family
talk to the camera
the first thing that wanda actually does
is look over to her side and feel for
vision
but of course he is not there and this
is actually kind of interesting because
the last thing that she did or the last
thing that we saw her do
was extend the hex borders so she could
actually save vision but as we find out
in this episode
vision is still lying on the floor from
where he fell when he got
outside of the hex so wanda didn't
actually go
look for him after she expanded the hex
but she sees that he's not there and
she's starting to realize that
everything is falling apart her world is
falling apart the perfect reality that
she's seemingly controlled and this is
also demonstrated when the twins come up
and say
our game is freaking out and we can see
that the controllers are warping they go
from nintendo wii controllers to uno
cards
the twins are still wearing their colors
true to their comic book counterparts
billy or wiccan is wearing red and tommy
or
speed is wearing green and although they
are not wearing their comic accurate
costumes like they sort of did in the
last episode
they're still sticking true to their
colors now when wanda gets out of the
bed she is still wearing her
what she called a sakovian fortune
teller costume
again showing us that right after she
extended the hex border she went
straight home
and went to bed she didn't go and look
for vision and the reason that she
didn't go look for vision is probably
because she's trying to avoid
facing what the actual reality is she
knows that whatever reality they're in
right now
isn't real and she doesn't want it to
end so therefore she doesn't want to
confront vision because at this point in
time he's pretty much aware of what's
going on
and wanda knows that and wanda realizes
that everything's pretty much about the
end which is why she kind of takes a day
to herself and really doesn't care
anymore when she walks down from
upstairs she looks at the twins and they
look at her but she kind of doesn't
really give them attention she tells
them one second and continues on to the
kitchen later on she tells the twins
that she knows they look up to her for
answers but she doesn't really have any
then when agnes or agatha hartness comes
in she uses her magic to open the door
not caring at all that she sees it and
says that she would get up but she
doesn't want to
want to go straight for the fridge and
we can see some product placement in
here with some canada dry and some
florida's natural but then we also see
some senka coffee in there now senko was
originally created by a team of
researchers in
germany and it was first sold in germany
and many other european countries around
it
so this would have most likely been the
coffee that wanda would have drank being
in sokovia
and it seems like in this was once a
perfect world for her she has her coffee
she grabs the almond milk which is a
west view dairy product of course
westview being the city that they're in
she then grabs a cereal called sugar
snaps
now there is a cereal called sugar
smacks but this is obviously
snaps referencing the snap obviously the
snap plays a huge part in her backstory
thanos killed vision in order to get the
infinity stones to snap
and when he finally did snap she was one
of the people who got snapped now the
milk carton kind of digresses and wanda
is a little bit confused because she's
not the one controlling it as she goes
to pour the milk into the bowl we can
see that there's a missing child posted
on the back of it
this is what they used to do in older
milk cartons they would put missing
photos of children on the back
and this is also foreshadowing that she
herself is about to lose her kids
they're about to go missing
wanda again talks to the camera just
like the people from modern family would
talk to the camera and says she doesn't
really know what the reality warping was
about
further implying that this world is
falling apart and wanda never really had
that much control over it it was really
all agatha then we get the best one
division intro that we've got
so far an office intro if you don't
watch the office and don't know the
office intro go watch it right now on
youtube
now randall park who plays jimmy woo
actually was in an episode of the office
playing asian gym playing a prank on
dwight obviously the real gem is john
krasinski and of course everybody is now
trying to make the connection between
the office introduction
john krasinski and the introduction of
reed richards into the mcu who everybody
believes is going to be played by the
man himself
john krasinski now if john krasinski is
indeed playing mr fantastic this would
be
very very meta and absolutely awesome
for marvel to do
but at the same time remember marvel
studios is playing off of sitcoms for
one division and we
finally progressed into the 2000s in
which the office and modern family were
extremely popular television shows
having said that the engineer was not
revealed to us in this episode and could
very well be reed richards but more on
that in a bit
the intro ends by saying one division
created by
wanda maximoff which at this point isn't
really true because we know that agatha
was behind everything
but it also looks like agatha was the
one kind of making everything into a
sitcom so if agatha was trying to
convince
wanda that she was in control she would
say that it was created by her
now in the next scene we go to director
hayward he's accompanied by a colleague
and they reveal that the signal is no
longer active
they're no longer picking up the wanda
vision series now this could be due to
what wanda did at the end of last
episode but it's more likely due to the
fact that agatha pretty much knows it's
time to grab the twins and is no longer
trying to keep the appeal of the sitcom
style theme that they had going on or if
the signal was coming from wanda it's
very clear that she doesn't care anymore
so she's probably not broadcasting that
anymore
now as hayward is talking he says we
launch today
and all throughout the episodes of one
vision we learned that
sword which used to be sentient world
observation and response division
is now the sentient weapon observation
and response division
is making sentient weapons that's one of
the reasons that hayward
had vision he was trying to make
sentient weapons out of him so when
hayward says launch
he's most likely referring to some type
of a weapon maybe even a different type
of
ultron it's very clear that they were
dissecting vision who was supposed to be
ultron so if they modeled their own
weapon
off of vision using some type of ai this
could really be just a new form of
ultron
after all ultron can't really die he's a
computer he exists within the internet
he can transfer his
what i'll call for a lack of a better
word consciousness into different robots
and connections so i'm betting that we
haven't seen the end of ultron in some
way or shape
then we return to vision where he was
last left wanda expanded the borders of
her hex barrier and in doing so
sucked in a lot of the sword agents and
darcy as well which we see
the sword agents turned into circus
characters which is pretty much a
reflection on how wanda views them
they're kind of just a bunch of clowns
to her specifically because she knows
that hayward
stole vision's body and was trying to
turn him into a weapon and make weapons
out of him the sword agent who used to
be hayward's right-hand man walks up
division and he's dressed in a strong
man costume you can see the s
on his belt which stands for sword this
is something similar that happened to
monica when she went through the barrier
her name
tag which was a sword name tag got
changed into a sword
necklace so something on this soldier
perhaps his sword badge got changed into
a sword belt
now wanda agatha's hex is still intact
here as we can see
these characters truly believe that they
are in a circus and he tells vision that
he's late for rehearsal with the escape
artist and the escape artist ends up
being darcy and even though darcy
absolutely knows who vision is and has
been watching this whole entire time has
no idea who he is inside of the hex
now in the next scene wanda asks the
twins where's your dad
she still hasn't seen him from that
night before when she had to expand the
hex to keep him alive
the twins ask if she wants them to go
look for them but again
wanda kind of doesn't care at this point
and is starting to embrace the fact that
she doesn't actually control everything
she says well if he doesn't want to be
here
there's nothing i can do about it
whereas before
like in the second episode if there was
something she didn't like she simply did
a retake
now here the twins start asking about
their dad and how uncle p
said that he could die again and wanna
drops the bomb that
that man uncle p or quicksilver is not
their uncle
despite what happened last time and the
somewhat of comfortability that she got
around him she knows that he truly isn't
her brother he is not the
aaron taylor johnson quicksilver who
died in age of ultron
so as the walls of the reality are
falling apart wanda is slowly realizing
that she's not the one doing
all of this there's somebody else
clearly behind it and quicksilver is
looking pretty ces
but she doesn't actually know who he is
and she doesn't really care
wanda is falling back into her
depression and she says that she's
starting to believe that everything is
meaningless but the kids can make their
own conclusions because she doesn't
really know what's happening
and judging by the kids facial
expressions after receiving that answer
from mom
they're pretty confused as to what's
happening wanda then addresses the
camera saying that that was probably a
little too dark but their father
vision is made out of vibranium and they
literally inherited
tough skin although i don't believe that
vision is the father as i mentioned
before
now the all too convenient neighbor
agnes stops by
right when wanda seemingly needed her to
wanda without even looking at the door
and knowing who's there uses her magic
to open it and says hi agnes come on in
then we start to get some very peculiar
lines wanda said agnes you are a
lifesaver which is ironic because it
seems like agnes is kind of about to
kill her twin boys
when tayonna paris the actor who plays
monica rambo was asked to describe the
last three episodes of wanda vision
she did say that they were incredibly
sad and considering the fact that agnes
took the twins and wanda can't find them
and she is actually agatha hartness
we could probably conclude that the
twins are already gone
or they might be soon so agatha is
literally the exact opposite of a
lifesaver she asks wanda to look at them
all on her back wanda gets a little
freaked out and agatha
says boundaries i get it now this of
course
is referencing the hex boundaries which
of course agatha helped create
which is why she gets it when they leave
wanda looks at
a plant to her right and there is a note
on this but i can't make it out so if
anybody can tell what this says be sure
to let me know
but it all of a sudden changes and just
like everything else in the reality has
been changing it looks like it is
digressing it is going back in time
everything kind of starts off as modern
in the era that they're in in the 2000s
but then it goes backwards
this represents her reality she had this
perfect reality where everything is
exactly how she wanted it to be but now
it's about to go backwards
big time she's falling back into
depression she's about to lose her kids
and
possibly even vision now in the next
scene with monica and jimmy they find
out that darcy before getting sucked
into the hex actually broke through the
firewall
and she emailed them and as we can see
from the email we discovered that
hayward was actually trying to bring
vision back to life but was unsuccessful
he wanted to use vision as a weapon and
he's so interested in vision now because
wanda managed to bring him back to life
we can also read in the email that it
says he tried over and over but nothing
worked until wanda stole vision's body
this is a decoy communique he sent to
vision's office
so that email from sword that vision got
in a previous episode was actually a
trick
from hayward he wants vision so he was
trying to locate him and get him now
we're led to believe that we're finally
going to meet the engineer that monica
has been talking about and as they
approach a site with some soldiers
she says look there they are now there's
a few things to note here if you've seen
the episode you know that we were not
introduced to the engineer
we are introduced to a agent goodner
however monica did say they and agent
goodner kept saying
we which is seemingly conferring to that
person and the engineer
so i believe this person could be on
site and as
monica and jimmy are pulling up to the
site we can actually see
two people that are in the background
there's one on the left who isn't
wearing a military uniform and is kind
of dressed as a civilian
he's not wearing a sword coat he's
wearing jeans a shirt and what looks to
be a jacket
this could be that engineer she never
said that the engineer worked for a
sword but the
engineer could have gotten the help from
sword and this would be why the engineer
would be dressed in normal clothes not
in a military outfit or sword outfit and
i must say that this person
does kind of look like john krasinski of
course he's off in the distance and you
can't really tell
but from a distance it does kind of
resemble him so perhaps the engineer
is indeed reed richards now they bring
out the vehicle that was specifically
designed by the aerospace engineer to go
inside of the hex
now there's a number on the face of it
on the right side that says 9219-r
and i looked this up and what i found on
this is 9219 is part of an isbn number
for young avengers presents number six
now i think it's all but confirmed that
the young avengers will eventually come
to the mcu
especially if billy and tommy do manage
to make it out alive
and this could be a little easter egg
towards that now ultimately the vehicle
can't get through and monaco manages to
escape
however she does decide to try and go
through it herself believing that she
can
make it through and thanks to her newly
found power she does make it through and
she comes out the other side as the hero
photon and as she comes out of course
her clothes got changed and now she
looks like the actual superhero photon
from the comics
meanwhile wanda's reality is slowly
falling apart and she doesn't know
what's happening
we have the nexus commercial which i
talked about in the beginning and it's
tied to agatha harkness and possibly
mephisto
nightmare or her son nicholas scratch
and agatha has the twin boys you can
notice that she is no longer wearing her
brooch or necklace that she's always
worn
some people have theorized that the
brooch actually has her and the two kids
on it
but when wanda sees her later on she
does have it on so perhaps this will be
revealed in a later episode
she does however mention her husband
ralph again and at this point in time i
think it's very clear that her husband
is probably
the villain i've been speaking about
either mephista or nightmare and the
reason that we haven't seen him yet
is because he is not yet on this realm
he's not yet in
our dimension and that's what she's
trying to do and that's why she needs
the kids
now vision and darcy try to make their
way back to wanda and vision's house and
vision thinks that it's wanda who's
putting all these obstacles in the way
to try and keep vision from returning
home but in reality it's agnes
or i should say agatha harkness vision
does seem to kind of understand where
wanda is coming from now though after
listening to what darcy had to say
of what happened to wanda before
westview and vision made it very clear
that he was very concerned about his
kids the kids are no doubt going to
unite wanda and vision
in the final episodes and they'll come
together along with monica
aka photon to fight agatha and then
vision and darcy are pretty much out for
the rest of the episode
monica makes her way into wanda's house
and wanda is not happy about it
she mentions hayward and wanda snaps
wanda uses her powers
throws monica up in the air and slams
her to the ground but
monica has her new powers so she's not
hurt however while this is happening the
neighbors
are noticing and we finally see dottie
for the first time
in a very long time the mailman is also
noticing what is happening these two
characters could be involved in agatha's
plan somehow but that will have to be
revealed in another episode
when monika and wanda are fighting
monica says don't let hayward
make you the villain and she replies
maybe i already am
now at this point she's led to believe
that she is the one who created
everything that is happening in west
view
however she doesn't know how it all
started agatha most likely started it
but wanda believes it was her so she
believes she's the villain
and speaking of agatha she comes and
interrupts agatha takes wanda back to
her house and wanda is starting to
notice that the children
aren't there she looks around to look
for the kids and she spots an insect on
the curtains
now this insect isn't exactly a fly but
it does resemble one
and in the comics guess who first
appeared as a fly
the demon mephisto more proof that
agatha is trying to bring him into this
realm
as i mentioned before agatha
intentionally tells wanda that she
thinks the kids are playing in the
basement so wanda will go into the
basement and see her layer
now as wanda walks into the main part of
her lair we see a lot of different
things
and remember agatha is very very old
she's thousands of years old so some of
these things are ancient
we see many different things including
what seems to be the skull of a ram
some ancient witch symbols on top of the
archways lots of different skulls
collected
and some cases that seemingly have a red
glow to them
then of course we see the dark hold that
i explained in the beginning it's evil
magic flowing out of it
and perhaps the biggest easter eggs that
we see here is the face of what is
seemingly
a demon on the pillars in her lair agnes
comes in
and reveals the truth about her that she
is agatha harkness
then she gets her own little intro
revealing that it has been
agatha all along she's been responsible
for everything
including quicksilver returning and as i
predicted from the last episode
she was faking when she was talking a
vision she just wanted vision to get far
away from wanda and the kids
and unfortunately she reveals that she
is indeed a witch
because she killed sparky the dog and
that's where the episode ends with her
laughing very evilly just like the witch
that she is
given the mephisto easter eggs that we
have seen in this episode i do believe
that he is the one or a combination of
him
and nightmare that she is trying to
bring into this realm and she needed the
kids
because they are part of the soul of
mephisto and or nightmare
and since a part of him is now in this
realm they can fully bring him into the
realm as well
but be sure to let me know what you
thought about this episode of
wandavision and let me know if you think
that agave is trying to bring in
somebody else from a different realm
be sure to subscribe for more breakdown
videos of wandervision and of course
theories about marvel in general be sure
to like the video if you enjoyed it and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof